good morning kick it's Tuesday so people
often ask me why I'm obsessed with
tuberculosis and this is why in 2019 I
visited the lecat tuberculosis Hospital
in Sierra Leone and met this boy Henry
who shares a name with my son and seemed
about the same age Henry immediately
began walking me around the hospital
showing me the grounds and introducing
me to various staff members and I
thought he must be like a child of a
nurse or something but when I spoke
later to one of the doctors he told me
Henry is a patient and one we're very
concerned about it turns out that Henry
was not nine years old like my son he
was 16. it's just that his body had been
ravaged by tuberculosis so after I found
out Henry was a patient I asked him how
he was feeling
but that turned out to be false hope
Henry had been a great student before
getting sick he dreamed of attending
University and his mother isatu worked
incredibly hard to pay for his school
fees she ran a small business selling
scented oils and perfumes at a local
market but by the time I met Henry he
was completely out school and had been a
full-time patient at laca for more than
two months receiving these injections to
treat his multi-drug resistant
tuberculosis the injection treatment is
super toxic it causes permanent hearing
loss in up to 20 percent of patients it
can also cause liver and kidney failure
but it was the only option available to
Henry now there was a better and less
toxic treatment protocol involving the
drug badakaline that had been available
for years in the United States and other
rich countries but it was deemed too
expensive by global Health authorities
and so people like Henry couldn't access
it in fact even the injections were
relatively new in Sierra Leone at the
time as Dr Jerome tafera explained to me
before PIH if you have immediary TV
before 2017 yes you are waiting for the
time of your list and so the injections
were an improvement but unfortunately
they were not working for Henry he began
losing weight the swelling from the TB
invading his lymph nodes erupted into
open wounds and he was hemorrhaging so
much blood that he required blood
transfusions his mother I saw to had to
pay the equivalent of thousands of
dollars to support Henry's treatment
finding blood for blood transfusions and
other supplies that he needed and in the
process she lost her business and her
apartment but right about Dr tafera he'd
arrived in Sierra Leone a few months
after I first met Henry from his home
country of Ethiopia and he also
initially thought that Henry must either
be like a staff member or a child of one
because he was just so good at
encouraging the other patients and he
was so friendly and always helping
everyone but when he saw Henry's lab
work he became very very concerned
because the injectables had clearly
failed he later told me when I saw that
we have no option that's when I thought
we're going to lose this young kid and
Henry knew how sick he was and he also
knew what it meant because he'd seen his
best friend at laka die of multi-drug
resistant tuberculosis after the
injectables failed but as Dr tafera told
me in the field of TB you have to keep
trying so he called his colleagues at
Partners in Health and the Sierra
leonean Ministry of Health and he was
like look some of the drugs we need are
in Liberia some are in with Soto is
there any way that we can get them here
together to help save this kid yes it's
only one kid but like tell that to his
mother and maybe this one kid can be the
first of many I came home from that trip
just obsessed with tuberculosis a
disease that despite usually being
curable still kills over 1.5 million
people per year more than are killed by
malaria and HIV combined and I spent the
next few years trying to learn about the
disease and along the way I often
thought of and prayed for Henry but I
never had the courage to ask my friends
at Partners in Health what had happened
to him but finally when Sarah and I
returned to laca in 2023 I asked one of
the nurses there do you remember a
patient named Henry and she said Henry
of course he's here today he wanted to
visit to see you
[Music]
all right
Henry became the first person in Sierra
Leone to receive the bedakulin-based
cocktail and he improved extremely
quickly Dr tafera told me that it was
like magic within three weeks he went
from what would have been his deathbed
to walking and talking and laughing and
eventually he was cured and after more
than two years at laca he was finally
able to go home now again
is that what it feels like to be alive
again yeah Henry went back to school and
thanks to support from Partners in
Health he's attending the University of
Sierra Leone studying Human Resources
management he dreams of working in
business and of traveling the world oh
and he's just started a YouTube channel
and a Discord server on YouTube he makes
videos showing daily life in Freetown he
also does interviews with people in the
community and makes great Vlogs and he's
really excited to connect with our
community on YouTube and Discord and
elsewhere he currently only has four
subscribers on YouTube and if I know
nerdfighteria I think we can bump that
up but as is often the case with TB
survivors Henry's life remains really
really challenging I mean their family
lost both their business and their home
I speak to Henry regularly and I told
him that our community may be able to
help out with that I satu really wants
to restart her business this time
selling food like macaroni and sugar and
cereal but in order to do that she needs
to be able to buy large quantities of
those goods and then rent space in a
market which is expensive so I've
started a GoFundMe in the hopes of
funding that dream and helping Henry
lift his mother out of poverty Henry is
here with us because of extraordinary
efforts made by himself by his family by
Charities by his caregivers and by his
government he gets to be here he gets to
have a YouTube channel and hopefully
connect with lots of you and help you
Glimpse what his life is like he gets to
figure out Discord and take tests and
hang out with his friends and try to
help his mom but none of that should
require extraordinary efforts Henry
never should have become so sick that
his mother lost her life savings he
should never have missed years of school
and he should never have been denied
access to badaquiline simply because of
where he was born and unfortunately all
of that is still happening millions of
times over to kids around the world and
that's why I'm obsessed with
tuberculosis and I know it's worth the
fight because of Henry because he's here
with us
Hank you'll find links to Henry's
YouTube and Discord and fundraiser in
the doobly-doo below I will see you on
Friday